[Applaudissements]
enrico macias leila ghanan à l'abricot
et macias
ils sont beaux ils sont forts ils sont
grands ils gagnent toujours
dallas a enfin la plupart du temps qu il
gagne un [ __ ] j'étais avec la petite
chaumière les fracasser fils au pourquoi
rapport à l'an qué mais non j'ai [ __ ]
gelé éclaté et je t'ai fait kiffer ah
oui bien sûr à vrai dire en quoi les
cheveux sera pas du tout un coin dans
les racines c'est une cape à ce qui t'a
fait j lo band où les chevaux mollet va
signer ton qu on voit les racines au ça
me coûtait 8000 la couleur une cata on
va toutes les races nouveau les racines
on se dit oh [ __ ] été installés vie
aux médias c'est ce qui s'est vraiment
tu dis moi rêver il paraît que les
fleurs ghrenassia se lancer dans le
trafic de contrôle turc orhan quelque
chose que tu as eu du flair kenya mais
aux arrêtés a indiqué l école massacre
rossellat couscoussière à terre et que
personne ne bouge
attends attends vite et bien car on
venait là là là c'est pas du tout
secousse mais en tout cas c'est bon
c'est pas du couscous est pas au niveau
souhaité de ses poings desserrés